I’m constantly amazed how we as a society do not speak truthfully or honest
to the people closest to us
We think it’s hard to speak directly and we’re never fully truthful
just to spare hurting someone's feelings
why do we do that?
I know not all circumstances are the same,
but why are we so afraid to be honest?
Don’t we want to surround ourselves with people
who are willing to tell us the hard truth?
How do we grow individuals if we're simply not willing to hear it?
I need people around me that are truthful and honest
even if it comes at the expense of my own feelings
you're simply not helping me,
if you can't be honest with me,
don't dodge the issue,
don't hesitate or withhold information from me,
just tell me how it is
don't tell me lies to my face just so you can spare my feelings
so society believes that that's helpful,
when really it's far from it
I would 100% rather have my friends or people closest to me telling me how it is,
than lie to my face.
The people closest to you really should have your best interest at heart,
so they should be willing to be upfront with you and honest,
They should be direct and truthful to you
even if it's hard and it hurts your feelings at times.
basically what's the point of comforting someone with a lie?